the flame-throwing closer to wrapped up
the 1996 all-star game a lighter of MLB
Network right here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you I'm doing great
so yes sir please there's a story behind
that it's my firt oh yes all right
probably not doing a star but yes sir
don't give any money the Rich Eisen show
so rich yes my first all-star game right
I had my troubles early on Yankees
blisters shoulder problem go to Toronto
yeah I'll finally figure it out 1996
throw the no-hitter yeah yep picked for
the all-star team I was told before that
Bobby Cox you know there's a handful of
guys that were gonna pitch as they do
every year and I was one of them that
wasn't the game's on I'm in the bullpen
with a handful of other all-stars and
Bobby Cox calls down and he says to
Bobby dude who is his one of his coach
he said get get lighter on the phone he
pick up the phone now I grew up get him
on the phone
up just get him on the phone so what was
cool about I grew up a Mets fan I get
drafted by the Yankees I'm 65 miles I
grew up from Yankee Stadium we went to a
lot of games at the vet because it was
easy in New Jersey where I'm in Ocean
County to just drive to the vet yeah so
it was really cool he says wow it's
cocky
like yeah hi hi mr. Cox he says uh he
says you you want up you want to get in
this game I said I would love to it'd be
great he says ok rollers gonna get the
first two outs
hurry up because literally the night
that he's starting and you'll get the
last out of the game and I was forever
grateful and indebted to him why every
time that I saw got his own guy to do it
right yeah he just he well for one the
game didn't count yes so you know and he
appreciate it you know I was with the
Mets and we were now becoming rival I
wasn't with the Mets yet no I'm sorry
yeah but you know within the division he
saw me pitch deserving anyway it was
just one of those moments where I
literally run in I threw about five or
six pitches to Wilson and then fly out
to my guy in Gary Sheffield I thought it
was really cool here we are on the eve
of you know yeah tonight you know I mean
that's that's great what's your first
all-star memory though I mean just
growing up and
watching I mean what was that okay so
I'm fifty to my most impressionable time
you know was definitely through the
seventies right yeah right anytime your
guy your team was represented for some
reason I can't believe it
Lee Mazzilli in Seattle yeah in the Mets
uniform those tight pants he wore he was
he he was still in the Sergio Valente
whatever who is definitely in so or in
the Cerrone ten jeans
so he goes right member homerun yeah it
was I got you know was the Mets I don't
know what year that was it was PI like
79 it was big cuz Lee Mazzilli in New
York City he's the man I think his Ron
do gay excuse me night I think I think
Lee Mazzilli 's dad was the piano tuner
in my house yeah cuz we had a piano and
you need a piano tuner was Lee Mazzilli
I think that's true I think that is
absolutely true
yeah and stat now in New York I mean
we're pretty much from the same area
so prior to we'd getting in the all-star
chat what do you think I Machado going
to the Dodgers what do you think that al
it's fine it looks like it wow I mean
Bob Nightingale is saying that it's
gonna happen so Bob Bob knows well you
know it's just like the language of the
information men and women in all sports
its barring last-minute expected to
plans to et cetera to go to the Dodgers
unless the Brewers or Phillies are none
other an unnamed team make a last-minute
pitch here yeah or all three teams make
sense right but right I think listen
when when Manny came out and um you know
basically said I'm a shortstop you know
what kind of eliminated I guess the
prospect of anybody who was thinking
about bringing him in a trade albeit for
only three months at their base so you
know with Seger down I mean makes sense
it makes sense it Milwaukee made sense
to shortstop I know that their numbers
at Short so I I figured that was gonna
happen right the depth of the roster of
the Los Angeles Dodgers really has been
what I've you know looking at their team
most impressive with the all of them
signs that they've done mm-hmm well it
puts him right back in it doesn't it
though I mean it's amazing how things
can change just about six weeks ago
everybody thought that they had
they were out of it and diamond back to
running away with it right now just to
get the exact numbers they are they lead
the Diamondbacks by a half game and if
Machado comes and that live show
starting right last view it makes it max
Chelsea doesn't it makes sense for us to
go ahead and do that ya know and it's
not surprising right I mean think they
can they get the deep pockets it's you
know they're gonna be able to so who do
you think is is gonna win this league
nationally I mean what do you think what
do you think's got a good shot here huh
listen I I think the fact that the Nats
really haven't gotten going if you will
I mean just looking at you know the
rotation and and what you know you know
improving their bullpen I just thought
you know with Bryce Harper and his walk
here like there's so much to say right
okay I get it it's upside down obviously
who would have thought I knew that the
Phillies were gonna be better based on
what they did certainly get an Arrieta
and Santana yeah
first place at the break amazing eyes
man he wasn't like 6166 Game+ sure I'll
figure that out we gotta lose now I'm
nodding his head right there they were
close they got 53 wins were amazing so
that turnaround
we knew Atlanta was gonna be better
based on those trades that they made a
few years ago so that was but the East
is definitely upside down you know the
Cubs are gonna start getting figuring it
out I really like the Brewers big-time I
mean I think you do yeah I do I do out
there this hey sis Aguilar I mean the
other thing we can talk about like who's
gonna win the National League MVP I
think the American League it's gonna
come down and Mookie Betts and you know
of course Mike Trout hmm but you know
that's also kind of gray all over the
place hey soos Aguilar I like this kid a
lot I like him he does it with a smile
he has Flair and um you know will they
get enough pitching I think that's the
thing for the for the Brewers and you
know the Cubs would be there and yeah
the West
I guess he always had to assume that the
Dodgers gonna we're gonna be there Al
Leiter here on the Rich Eisen show I
just talked to the Commissioner about
what Tony Clark said gaining momentum
and what's gaining momentum is the
designated hitter in the National League
what do you think about that idea if I
was playing right now I would say no way
for obvious reasons
what cuz you wanted leg out a triple
like you did that one time so well
actually I don't know if it I don't know
if they got on the air so I was
listening to your the shift thing right
cuz that's gaining momentum and I can't
tell you how many times that I talked to
Major League
but hitters s2 and i did this from work
to share a few years ago when I was
doing some games for the yes no I said
Tex this would you would make the
today's show you'd make Good Morning
America bunt 56 times and your first
about nobody on of course like you know
if it's a compelling part of the game
and you got guys on base but 56 bunts
nobody's playing on the left side of the
infield you know it doesn't have to be a
good one right and you'd break Joe
DiMaggio streak with 57 against the
shift against the [ __ ] like just try it
that's what I thought
I get paid to hit homeruns I get paid to
drive the ball I get paid to hit
homeruns I get paid I think alright I
get it
I said you know and then I started
taking a poll on like is it really that
difficult that's genius to go the other
way
geez how cool would that be right 56
game hitting streak
Martin Pagan Mark Teixeira but anybody
who had the big shift that he's on his
fifty seventh consecutive bunt shift god
I wish it made it cuz when I was coming
over here actually Lou who does their PR
yeah he we pulled up the double I said
if I could pull up my the first hit I
ever had in the big leagues
lots of rolling right here rich in the
boys I said here take this for every
major hitter say cake go the other way
boom oppo pass Thompson yeah I know I
come I come in Gucci lugging it up okay
knees and John Kruk right there is
saying all sorts of fun things that I
can't use on me I don't know how many
hits Kruk II had up to that point but I
don't think it was that man he's a crook
he's 300 lifetime hitter look at awful
swing well so one of the worst somebody
gave you a karate Mason he Mikey right
down a man rich I didn't have an it bad
for 10 years
[Laughter]
high school that was County New Jersey
and I got a double in the World Series
what a joke okay seriously one of the
one of the worst hitters that ever stood
in major league batter's box
my next at-bat yes that was in that was
a World Series 93 yeah is when I with
them with the Marlins I signed with
tomorrow's my first game against the
Pirates
the next pitch yeah by guy by the name
of John Eric's Big O right-hander yeah
right down the middle
walk base hit up the middle like you
should be my Costanza you should have
walked that's it you walk off speaking
of that didn't Kruk do that what's he
when he was or what White Sox he got a
hit to get to 300 right 20 quit and he
quit and he packed his stuff during the
game and drove back to West Virginia
yeah he's like I'm having as a 300
hitter I guess then the D H would remove
that sort of fun stuff from the game I
mean listen I'm in a league I know if
we're talking about pace of play you
know I I think I shouldn't say this cuz
I don't know the fact but I think
American League games are a bit longer
fair enough huh you know you should
cruise through I did the Yankees Nats
game here a few weeks ago that right now
yes game and all that we had one game
that was like two hours and 28 minutes
or something I'm as beautiful it was
crisp you know I know it sounds like I
shouldn't be saying that but it you know
it just it was moving you know we're one
or two three pitches boom pop up fly
ball ground ball whatever just bolts and
play I get it why is it that if it's if
it's such an awful idea there's two
leagues on the planet mmm-hmm that has a
pitcher hit so National League one of
the two in the Japanese leeks either
Central League or pacifically he got me
on that one I'm the planet right
everywhere else you have a hitter
hitting in place of a pitcher
I think the traditionalists who go crazy
about everything and I'm there is back
in February I don't know if I've had you
on lately but back in February a very
high-ranking official in baseball and
who's got some power in baseball said
that they they're they would love to put
an idea in baseball it hasn't gotten
there that you could rearrange the
lineup
in the ninth-inning with anybody put
anybody up you want if you're losing
I've heard that and then people went
nuts over that I was accused of stealing
the idea is accused of ruining baseball
but there's all sorts of crazy I can't
imagine if that's if that rule right I
mean I know you just heard the
Commissioner on about a minor league
game there right that people thought
that was kind of cool supporting second
man on second to start the extras to
start extra innings yeah which to me I
think if you do that in the regular
season that's that's great like hockey
has a different set of rules for
overtime in the regular and postseason
maybe baseball should do that too yeah
so I know in youth baseball
I mean watched a lot of games from my
son in extra innings they do I think
it's called the California rule where
it's first and second mmm-hmm not only
just second and you start the inning
mm-hmm the next raining so you know
speed up there's time games why is that
the California I don't know I think it's
called the Caliph is it involve on it
avocado man if you don't mind let's
finish the show up here Al Leiter when
we come back we'll ask him the poll
question as well about who you'd want to
start a team with and then I gotta ask
y'all just give you a few minutes your
best Billy Martin story all right I
gotta get that for me I gotta get you
good the best Billy Marvin so many
people I tell people I played for Billy
Martin and Tommy John was by tape my
teammate they're like cuz you're not
you're not out lied are here on the Rich
Eisen show on all-star Tuesday in
Washington DC
all right I'm sure exit team is waiting
by the phone right now if you want to
get out of your timeshare for whatever
reason they will find out the proper
approach for you and get you out or give
you a full refund they're an accredited
trusted company give them a call right
now timeshare eggs a team at eight
hundred nine seven five three one six
seven that's eight hundred nine seven
five three one six seven online at three
two one exit dot-com I want to thank
today's guests Hall of Famers Johnny
Bench and Pudge Rodriguez the
Commissioner of baseball Rob Manfred and
ul ladder appreciate you coming out here
today ask him the poll question Chris
Brockman the final and give the final
results here yeah who would you build
your MLB franchise around which of these
guys they're all 26 and under Mookie
Betts Bryce Harper Aaron Judge Manny
Machado Mike Trout my truck my truck you
and bench said I I had him on he started
our show on MLB tonight and you know we
do these breakdowns yeah and I pulled up
he had a game five for five against the
Yankees earlier this year he had three
doubles and home run and the one that I
was most impressed with and I had him
roll the tape he hits a three hopper to
the right of DD and he beats it out last
year I did a Yankee angel game at the
stadium and it was a fly ball to right
Aaron judge caught it and it was a
clearly a now so I didn't once it was
hit you know it's gonna be nuts and I
watched I watched Mike Trout he was
about four steps almost at second base
I told him I told him Peru soar in the
air I said can you show that back but
just show Mike Trout running and it was
just like one of those moments that you
know not to be like the crotchety old
guy but he plays hard every aspect of
his game isn't playing hard there's no
throttle he doesn't step on the brake
once in a while I love that the quote
from Joe DiMaggio right why did you
always run it out and play hard because
there may be somebody who's gonna watch
me for the first time and last time
right ever you know they'd have
televisions sure and and and I'm just
wondering of how many of the hits in his
56-game hitting streak were bunts do you
think there will be a shift in a
all-star game tonight yeah are you
kidding weird like we're at sabermetrics
Central is all of these managers
what's the point oh where do you eat
what are we trying to achieve tonight
we're trying to give the best possible
show nobody is tuning in tonight or
buying a ticket to that station we're
here to see the third baseman create and
out by a ground ball and right face and
handshake agree then yeah you're right
you're right now that I said I think
they'll be shifts but I hope there isn't
there shouldn't be a damn shift I'm with
you I'm with you are they watching who's
listening AJ yeah Dave Roberts no Jeff
no no shift all right I got a minute for
your best Billy Martin story you got one
well I told you when I was lifting maybe
I didn't tell this story but I it was
after one of my starts I'm in the
training room and I'm lifting five pound
cuff weights doing the job exercises and
Billy comes in he's got his he's got his
long underwear on his shower shoes and
he's got a cigar in his mouth and he
walks past me and he says what's wrong
with you and I literally he's standing
right here and I turned around like
talking to me there's what's wrong with
your arm
I said nothing because why are you
lifting weights yeah lifting weights we
have a strength coach back then by the
way 87 so I guess or 88 he says you want
to strengthen your baby baby arm you go
out and long toss so I used to hide my
kid we used to have a drum room Beckett
like he used to play drums yeah then I
would go back and hide in the bowels of
Yankee Stadium wouldn't lift the
five-pound weights cuz I was afraid of
Billy getting really mad at me cuz he
told me not to lift weights think our
like out that's old school old school
you want to strengthen your arm you go
out and long toss I'm lifting by weight
like sweating to the oldies but you know
I mean Billy but you know yeah stay away
from Billy Harper's dad meanwhile last
night looked like the Hulk
yeah I know
that was great yeah great to see you
good to see you if you're ever in Los
Angeles let's let's do it but otherwise
let's let's chat on the thank you at
underscore lighter 22 on MLB Network
check him out again thanks to Johnny
Bench Pudge Rodriguez Rob Manfred an
ally tour tomorrow Jake Tapper fresh
back from Helsinki will be here and our
front on our final day it's part of the
fun that we will have and we
obviously reviewed tonight's hopefully
no shift free all-star game I'm gonna
mention it let's do that okay do that
thank you how lighter the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience